All right, prophecy.
Now think of it this way.
If the Bible is both accurate and trustworthy,
and we can know it to be true,
or we can also know it to be historical,
what then does that say about prophecy?
Prophecy is tricky.
It's almost like we can believe
that the Bible is accurate history.
We can show that and it's concrete
and it kind of aligns up with some other things.
And we can show that the Bible is completely accurate
across all of history,
and that 95% the same exact thing
that what Jesus actually said or whatever.
Prophecy is trickier
because prophecy can be something
that you might just discount and go,
well, that just sort of was the happenstance
or just coincidence.
And it just sort of happened that way
or maybe it was manufactured to look like
it was fulfillment of prophecy.
So here's the deal with this week.
As you go through piece by piece,
as you walk students through the misconceptions
and the illuminations,
as you walk your students through
and help guide them
through their introduction activity
and exploration of Isaiah chapter 52 and 53.
As you look at the questions
and you start to piece this whole week together,
I want you to keep one thing in mind this week
and that's it.
This week could be a difficult week.
This could be the week, one of those weeks
that students start firing all kinds of questions at you,
especially your small group leaders.
So here's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna write the questions down
and we're gonna dig in and do some research.
And I want you to come back if you have to
even take an addition week to answer those questions.
Don't pretend like you have all the answers.
Now you might have a bunch of the answers
and that's awesome.
But if you don't,
don't pretend and don't brush it off
because we're sort of at that moment now
where you probably have students that are like,
especially if they started very skeptical,
hopefully they're walking closer and closer
and closer and closer.
But the closer you get,
the easier it is to just fall off the edge
because if we discount a question,
the train may just come off the rails
and it's maybe over.
I don't know.
So you wanna approach these kinds of things
very carefully.
You've spent so much time and energy
in developing authentic and organic community
and trust with these students
and openness and honesty
and being able to ask the difficult questions.
Now is one of those times
where the difficult questions are going to start to come.
But it comes to prophecy.
There just may be those kinds of things.
I can't predict what kind of questions your students
may ask, but from my experience,
this is always one of those areas
that just, it pops up.
So if you don't know the answers
or your small group leaders don't know the answers,
write them down, gather together,
get some answers,
bring your students back together
and give them the answers that they're seeking.
So for this week, don't be afraid
to directly address the misconception.
And here's how we've worded it.
It seems to be entirely impossible
for one man to fulfill hundreds of prophecies,
not to mention that the way Jesus fulfilled
Messianic prophecy was very much contrary
to popular Jewish theology.
Jewish leaders were looking for the coming Messiah
to be a political, military and spiritual ruler
that would dethrone foreign rule
and reestablish Israel as a world superpower.
Instead, Jesus unexpectedly established a spiritual kingdom.
It's a worldview shift that has prevented many
from accepting Him as Savior.
Keep that in mind.
This is a completely worldview shift for many.
It was that way for Jews in the first century
and it's that way probably for many
of your students as well.
Don't be afraid to hit the bell.